hi i'm jaz sinclair and i play rosalind
walker and i am lachlan watson i play
theo putnam from the chilling adventures
of sabrina and we are going to take a
buzzfeed quiz to see how well we
actually know each other
so who is jazz's favorite chilling
adventures of sabrina character well
i'm not even on here and i'm offended by
that harvey
madame satan zelda or you i'm great
if it's not me then i'm going to say
zelda
oh that makes sense i just think she's
hilarious
she's pretty good and unpredictable and
i love it lachlan's favorite chilling
adventures of sabrina character i
actually don't remember what
dr c said which i think it's that hilda
dorcas or melvin i'm gonna go dr c
no it's melvin oh i got it wrong
melvin's cog i think he's great and it's
also because tyler was right next to me
when i was answering these questions and
he said if i didn't put him he would get
very upset
so i said tyler who is jazz's celebrity
crush
ross noah centennial oh lucas
oh he's cute is it ross it's gonna be
ross isn't it
yeah yeah i thought it was cheeky who is
mike who is lachlan's celebrity crush is
it tilda swinton
prince no is it david bowie or rooney
mara i don't know man
is it rooney mara no no it's david bowie
i don't know that
it's more of like i want to be him who
from the cast would jazz consider to be
their bff is it kiernan shipka
me chance or tati i think it's
me it's you it's me you guessed right
you picked me too huh
did i i hope kiernan ross gavin or me
yeah that's cute we've been butts for a
minute yeah we've been bud's friends
for a minute yeah i think we knew from
the start we did like all right we've
been busy for a while you're the one
what's jazz's favorite food at crafty
is it finished dip pretzels chicken
salad we don't get that good spinach dip
no i'm gonna say pretzels what how did
you get pretzels
oh man oh and you just told me your
answer too
food it's not grilled cheese or tuna
salad or the fruit platter
it's pb and j it is it sure is
lachlan usually is the one to go grab
the pizza and then i'm the one to eat
them
mine usually yeah i come back and then
my pb and j's are gone well
our half of it's gone like a big like
i'll take out a big fight
yeah what's jazz's favorite movie of all
time
which is such a hard question mind you
that's so difficult it's so hard
is it titanic avatar her or star trek
i voted her and it's avatar only because
i watched that movie the other day and
cried like three times
what's lachlan's favorite movie of all
time the goonies
princess bride princess diaries oh never
ending story i feel like it's got to be
the goodies or the never-ending story
interesting i don't know i'm gonna go
goonies no you i love the princess bride
too so good
i love princess pride it has got to be
my fave who would jazz
pick to play themselves in a movie is it
kerry washington tracy ellis ross angela
bassett
or miss halle berry they're all so
beautiful they're all so pretty
you've got like a kerry washington vibe
going on right now fill it
i'm gonna go tracey ellis ross because
she's honestly i should have picked her
but i picked halle berry but i should
have picked
i think that's more just like who i wish
yeah would play me oh man who would
lachlan pick
rachel wood cara delevingne christian
stewart and till this one
evan no tilda swinton
same deal i'm like i want i would love
awesome to be played by taylor swinton
but it's just you know
i don't know if it's realistic it's a
dream you get to you get to create this
reality manifesting it's your rules
to call me what would jazz be if she
wasn't an actor
a teacher a painter a dancer a therapist
i'm gonna say a teacher
no yeah you would be a character i would
be a therapist it would be a very good
therapist
i know i like to listen what would
lachlan be if they weren't an actor you
know this
fashion designer makeup artist art
teacher model fashion designer
makeup artist i know you should have
known cause i offered to do your makeup
like an hour
you did you did what's jazz's
favorite netflix show aside from the
chilling adventures of sabrina ooh
i have a good guess for this because you
talked about it earlier i did
as opposed to sex ed elite are on my
blog
i'm gonna stay into the epping world
yeah nailed it
yes what's lachlan's favorite netflix
show aside from the chilling adventures
of sabrina
it's not big mouth it's not bojack
horseman it's sex ed
yeah that show is so good it's so
like petitioning i like to be like a
non-binary like american exchange
student
it's such a good show i would cry the
characters are also i genuinely would
cry
if jazz lived in greendale would she go
to baxter high or the academy of unseen
oh for sure the academy good
sure if jazz was in the cast of the
original tv show
who would she want to play i'm going to
say zelda
ah hilda you do so good with the like
thank you because honestly that's how i
like to feel if lachlan was cast salem
[Laughter]
how did you do i got 30 you don't know
me at all i got 15 out of 20.
i thought you were beating me no i went
i knew i was losing
what's my prize my undying love and
energy friendship
friendship friendship friendship
is the best [ __ ] there is
you